Okay.
Be honest.
What do you think?
Well, you're definitely on the right track. So, well done.
Your content is very clear and you maintain a good structure all the way through.
Thanks.
My first suggestion would be maybe to make it shorter, a bit more punchy.
Is it too long?
Well, there's some repetition in it and there may be material in here...
...that this audience doesn't need to know about.
Like what?
Why don't I mark it up on your script?
And then you can have the final say.
Great!
Thanks!
If you make the presentation shorter, you won't have to learn it word for word.
Have you considered using cue cards?
They're really helpful.
What are they?
Instead of using a script, just write down a few key words,...
...phrases on a card and they remind you as to what comes next.
Cue cards, they keep you on track,...
...help you structure your presentation.
Brilliant!
It'll give you confidence.
It works like a safety net, so if you're not sure what comes next, you just look at the cards.
I can see that.
It allows you to focus on the audience,...
...so you're not always looking down at the page.
That sounds scary.
Try to make eye contact and always be yourself.
It will make people feel like they're more comfortable...
...and they will be more responsive to what it is you're trying to say.
This is really helpful.
Thank you, Mateo.